the world is obsessed with these two yes
brad and jennifer reunited thanks to
comedian dane cook
and he was actually there and told us
that everyone's favorite former couple
has still got it
what's their chemistry like i think it's
just they're irresistible
you know you'll see you'll see in the
moment that they see each other
the greeting moment you just know right
there you're like
damn this is that's that that's that old
hollywood like all the way back to the
the 50s you know certain couples got
together and boom sparks so yeah
you see them you just see that there's
such a there's such a great
wonderful uh organic connection with
those two
i do yeah brad and jen's reunion for the
fast times at ridgemont high
virtual table read is everything we
hoped it would be
but here's the thing we know there are
some hookups in the sean penn cult
classic
so there's definitely romantic moments
in scenes with people that you'd like to
see
connecting with each other
[Music]
now you know what you did you just set
the world on fire relax
all right i put on 15 pounds just
staring at how beautiful that they were
they're charismatic because such pros
that i'm telling you they deliver a
quality high quality performance man
they're awesome
og surfer dude sean penn returns with
julia roberts
matthew mcconaughey john legend henry
golding and jimmy kimmel
joining brad and jen for the special
that was supposed to stream live last
month
it was postponed due to technical
difficulties
sean said don't give up on this man
we'll get there
and that's when everybody just rallied
during filming the cast hung out for
four hours with cameras rolling the
whole time
so there are plenty of bloopers hey bud
let's party the special benefits shawn's
emergency
relief nonprofit core and reform
alliance it streams tomorrow on coors
facebook and tick tock pages
who had the most outrageous prop who
brought the most
brad really i told you everybody came to
play man
wow he wore the pirate costume then huh
i'm not saying a pirate costume but i'm
saying brad
brad came to have some fun kevin you're
[Music]
good
you